the different scenes we'll have to jump around in
the trailer a little bit they start the trailer
with the voiceover from the younger version of
renera reading aegon's prophecy like his dragon
him so to speak they call it a dragon dream like
he had a dream about uniting the Seven Kingdoms to
defend against the long night these white walkers
that were coming this is also a version of her
just wearing plain clothes kind of sneaking past
the monument to blaring the black dread that we
just saw and she talks about the prince who was
promised like she's literally talking about Jon
Snow so like we got a bunch of Daenerys references
during episode one like they literally mentioned
Daenerys Targaryen now they're starting to mention
Jon Snow the funny thing about this Prophecy of
the prince who was promised is that it's written
as if aegon the Conqueror wrote it himself like
from his perspective and he talks about this
eventual heir of his who will be the eventual
prince who was promised it's the same prophecy
that rhaegar Targaryen spoke of during the
original Game of Thrones books because as visera
said during episode 1 it's a prophecy like it's
a secret this passed from King to Heir rhaegar
Targaryen was the heir to the Mad King so before
the Mad King went mad he would have told rhaegar
Targaryen about the long night in the night King
in the prophecy of the prince who was promised so
that's why rhaegar when Jon Snow was busy being
born was talking about that prophecy it's just
that later in the timeline when he was actually
born there was this added meeting he himself was
literally The Song of Ice and Fire his mother
lyanna Stark from the Frozen North and his father
rhaegar Targaryen of the Dragons so during episode
2 we'll be talking a lot about Jon Snow but the
actual scene that they cut it on top of is taking
place on Dragonstone later in the timeline and
this is the scene where you see the kingsguard
some of the Small Castle Otto Hightower coming to
stop Daemon Targaryen who has a dragon egg with
messeria here and you see a version of rhaenyra
flying on syrax to try and stop them and help
Daemon also Daemon's Dragon craxies nearby too so
it's like a really heated situation like he even
pulls his sword Dark sister on the kingsguard in
Otto Hightower here I think what's happening here
is that mysaria has gotten pregnant with Daemon's
bastard and he thinks that it's going to be
another Dragon Rider so he wants to give mysaria
a dragon egg so that the child will eventually
bond with the dragon become another Dragon Rider
legit but the whole thing is the dragon eggs to
the targaryens are more precious than gold like
the most precious resource course it'd be like
giving a nuclear weapon to another person like no
no you're not allowed to give away dragon eggs to
anybody you want so what happened is viserys
found out what was happening found out that he
was stealing one and sent them to stop him made
him give back the dragon egg also you have the
idea that Rhaenyra Targaryen really cares about
Daemon. Daemon really cares about Rainier so she
kind of sides with him so just more tensions
escalating between the two sides that will
eventually become the factions in the dance of the
Dragons just based on the Rock here it seems like
somebody is trying to sneak into Dragonstone you
see more of alicent hightower meeting with king
viserys I'm not sure which Castle this is supposed
to be because it looks kind of run down there are
a couple big castles that we haven't seen on
the show yet for some of the really important
characters that we'll probably see in the next
couple of episodes though we see one of the
targaryen's boats this dragon is caraxes Daemon's
Dragon this is the younger version of rhaenyra
with Laenor Velaryon. Corlys Velaryon's oldest
son they tried to get them married basically
so this is them just meeting near driftmark that's
where this is taking place driftmark is the island
right next to Dragonstone the seat of houseful
area on this is the older version of Rhaenyra
this could be from like episode 6 maybe a little
bit after I don't think it's from that late in
the episodes there are 10 episodes total so like I
don't think there's footage from like episode 9 or
10 or anything like that in this it's not totally
clear where she is in this scene because there's a
couple different places that you see her and most
of them are all about the Black Council basically
her crowning herself Queen of the Seven Kingdoms
I'll get to that in a second because there's like
one scene with her with the older version of
alicent and criston cole later in her life she
spent a lot of her time on Dragonstone so that's
why you see so many scenes of her on Dragonstone
when she's older this seems like it's the older
version of viserys coming to Dragonstone with a
kingsguard this is younger renera on Dragonstone
this scene of renera talking to rainey's seems
like it's happening relatively soon after the
big ceremony where she's named the official Heir
at the other Lords of the realm swear filthy to
her and I think she's trying to get real with her
like look they named you the air but there's no
way that this is gonna stick it looks like we're
gonna go to the great sept at some point during
the season then when you hear the older veneer
say I'm going to be Queen of the Seven Kingdoms
you see all these people assembled inside the map
table room in Dragonstone it's like her version
of the small council with all the people that
swear fealty to her because things have really
started to heat up in the actual Dance of the
dragons like there isn't actual battles between
them happening right now but this is like right
at the beginning like it actually starts to get
set off basically what winds up happening is
that eventually her father does wind up dying
and because of a couple important things that
happen there's a lot of confusion over who the
official Heir is like alicent isn't sure if he
wanted his new son like we see her pregnant with
viserys; child but they're not sure if he still
wanted rhaenyra to be Queen so there's all this
confusion and in the confusion in defiance of all
the craziness that's going on rhaenyra basically
says you know what screw this I'm Queen my father
named me air I'm going to be Queen so winds up
pissing a bunch of people off but like you see
a couple familiar faces here like you see some
of the Kings guards some of them swear fealty
to her not all the kingsguard and a lot of the
valerians because a lot of the marriages will
eventually wind up happening on the show all the
battle footage is from the wore the stepstones I
don't know if it's going to be like one battle or
a couple different battles Because the actual War
of the step Stones like this big battle with
a triarchy that they hyped up in episode one
like the track is becoming a problem this crab
feeder figure we should do something about it the
freeing victims that were tied up by crab feeder
he's called crab feeder because he tied them up
in low tide so that the crabs would literally come
in on high tide and feast on all the victims you
see older alicent pull the Valyrian dagger off of
her husband King Viserys push him to the ground
and then attack ranero with it obviously viserys
is still alive during this so the actual Dance of
the Dragons hasn't begun but it's just meant to
show you how things just continually deteriorate
between the two women that used to be the best of
friends this scene of older renera in Daemon seems
like after they eventually get remarried later in
the timeline a lot of stuff has to happen before
we get to that point so I'll just wait to talk
about that until it actually happens in episodes
like I said this is a scene of the younger Alicent
after she's been remarried to King Viserys he's
still very much alive she's become pregnant with
a new Heir for him it's a son named aegon II this
scene of frenero looking down at all the knights
here seems like it's relatively soon after the
ceremony to name her the heir where Criston Cole
is being named to the kingsguard like he's not
wearing the kingsguard armor yet there's also this
weird scene where you see rhaenyra with her father
viserys in the Valyrian dagger is in the fire
they're heating up and later you see her seems
like she stabs a dragon with the dagger we see a
bunch of dragon eggs in the trailer too they might
show us some more details about how they actually
used to hatch dragons and how they started Dragon
bonding after they had been hatched when Otto
Hightower is talking to the older version of
alicent I still think it's a little bit earlier
in the timeline this might have something to do
with the war of the stepstones just because of
the way the war was actually fought he's talking
to her about all this collateral damage happening
the war of the stepstones was against the triarchy
and crab feeder obviously it took several years
but the whole idea is that the actual War wasn't
fought with like the traditional King's Army
viserys did support the war with his gold but
it was mostly fought by Daemon Targaryen his
Dragon character's the forces of house velaryon
and corlys velaryon in a bunch of cell swords and
landless adventurers so it was sort of like this
ragtag group and corlys velaryon's men fighting
this giant War across several years in the
stepstones to try and stop this problem without
the help of the rest of the realm when we see
viserys yelling at Daemon on the ground here like
he's just kind of sitting there taking it from him
I think the reason he's yelling at him about not
being a conqueror is about what's happening in the
stepstones because in the other trailer you see
Daemon walking into the throne room with all the
other Lords the rest of Court assembled wearing a
crown himself what ended up happening is their war
against the triarchy was successful even though
their forces were way way smaller but when they
won all these battles Daemon basically named
himself King of the stepstones and was crowned
by corlys velaryon so that's the crown that he's
wearing here in the throne room and it probably
just winds up pissing off viserys and a lot of
the other Lords and that's probably why he's
so mad here but the other funny thing is there are
like so many WTF things that Daemon Targaryen does
to piss off viserys throughout what will probably
happen during season one that this could be any of
like four different things that he's yelling about
but I don't want to get too ahead of the trailer
footage there's a lot of really spicy stuff that
we'll just wait to talk about until it actually
happens in episodes speaking of which at the
wedding of Rhaenyra and Laenor Velayron Corlys
Velaryon's oldest son you actually see her staring
at Kristen Cole that's because she has like a real
big thing for him it does not go well I don't want
to talk too much about laenor velaryon but let's
just say he's kind of like a loras tyrell type of
figure so it's not a super happy marriage for an
era like she's forced to marry him by her father
when corlys velaryon says their houses are bound
by common cause that's probably just him agreeing
with viserys to marry their children together
because right after that you see some of their
children actually standing together much later
in the timeline like these two sons with the
brown hair are rhaenyra's sons the two girls